ownership was always very important to
me if i wasn't in this business i would
be an architect but
i wanted to not only just design the
house but build the houses and own the
houses and sell them
my father was a subcontractor and he
would get paid uh
on fridays and be so happy that he had
made 800 but i would watch the man that
owned the house
sell it and make 80 000 so i always knew
that there was more power
in the man that owned the house rather
than the man that actually was working
on it in building it so i always wanted
to be the guy
that owned the house so naturally when i
went into film and television it had to
be that way watching examples like oprah
owning the oprah winfrey show and and
understanding what that meant
that was very very important to me and i
think that um
i am a testament to anybody who wants to
get in this business ownership
changes everything you know when you
think about film
and television it's been done the same
way for years you know you record an
image
and and you put it out there well just
because it's been done that way for many
many years doesn't mean that there
aren't a lot of other things you can add
or change so
i just i don't like to go with the norm
or the status quo i like to challenge
the system and see what i can find
differently so
that is truly a disrupter so this is the
residence
they have two kids so
very close yeah
[Music]
their daughter's room
first time i came to um atlanta i was um
coming here for freaknik which is a
black spring break i was coming here at
the party
and hang out with all the other college
dropouts because i didn't even go
and uh but i saw black people doing well
i saw
doctors and lawyers i saw black families
going to restaurants and
living in nice houses and that was so
foreign to me coming from
uh coming from louisiana so getting here
seeing that being a part of that tasting
at him being in the air this was the 90s
where
there was this great migration to
atlanta but especially by black people
because they knew something special was
happening here well i was one of one of
the ones in that number
but it's also the home of dr martin
luther king and if you
if you really want to talk about
somebody who had a dream and all of his
adversities and things that he overcame
i just felt like being on this ground
breathing this air in these georgia
pines
would be everything i needed to become
all that i wanted to be
yeah in the beginning yeah i wrote all
the music
i um directed the show i would show up
and
hang the lights i was driving the truck
in the beginning yeah i'm no stranger to
hard work
that's the great thing about being in
this in the in the entertainment
business
there's not a job in this business that
i don't know well so having all these
people work for me i know what they're
doing
i couldn't walk down the street without
people screaming media tyler medea madea
and then i got to hollywood and they had
no clue no clue
to what i what i'd done who i was or the
following that i had so
i went to a couple of studios and and
they were like well we want to change
this we want to change that in your
script we want to change this
and da da da i'm like no not changing
that and i need to own it and i was
completely willing to walk away from
because i i have an audience that has
been so endearing to me so
uh powerful and so strong and so
my support my rock by my side they were
supporting me so well
i didn't need to be in hollywood it was
just a way to
for me to uh tell more stories without
having to show up
at 360 different performances every year
but
but ownership for me was easy because i
was underestimated they said sure you
could own it they didn't think it was
going to be worth anything
i feel like it was humble beginnings and
i feel like it's humble even more
humbling for me now
even having all of this access to things
it's really really great but
the the important part of all of that is
understanding what this is about that is
beyond me
and it takes people to really walk the
studio a lot and see the faces of all
these people around here who haven't had
a chance who haven't had a shot
to see them get their opportunity to see
them light up when they see themselves
on screen for the first time
that to me is is is the the motivation
the inspiration and everything i need to
keep going
i've been on many many movie sets around
uh
in my lifetime and to walk in and not
see one black face
are very few women on the set it's
always been
troubling to me i thought wow there is
not one black person
that that is working on this crew of
400. even if you just did the statistics
and the numbers
it it should make sense that there would
be at least one
so i wanted to foster an environment
where minorities and women and people
lgbtq anybody who wanted to come and
work and do a great job was
welcome what i found is that if you
invest in the underdog
if you invest in the people who haven't
had the opportunity the level of
gratitude and understanding
for what is happening for them is so
powerful it's just wonderful